the term designer babies is is used I
think it's more of a kind of tabloid
description but we know what we mean
where people where babies are then
having the screen for certain genetics
and certain genes they're taking out are
taken out or eliminated or played with
do you think that science is playing God
or do you think that's actually where we
need to get to as a species so thereby
eliminating certain illnesses diseases I
think it's hard to find an objection to
eliminating diseases so I think as long
as that's used not for making designer
babies but for
um
screening against hereditary diseases it
seems to me that that's really hard to
object to that
um do you not think there's a moral
conundrum there because it kind of
depends where you draw that line doesn't
it for example if you have a baby that's
I don't know has a higher risk of cancer
now I I have a a young son I wouldn't
want him to have have a higher risk of
cancer but if I could then you know
select them from a number of fetuses and
discard the others wouldn't that be
maybe perhaps too far going in that
direction well I don't think necessarily
so
um I suppose the way it might work this
would be something like this in IVF in
vitro fertilization
um the woman is given hormone treatment
to Super ovulate so she gets maybe a
dozen eggs and the dozen eggs are all in
in a petri dish
and what happens at present is that the
doctor picks out one of these eggs at
random they all get so fertilized as
they can picks out one of the zygotes
are random and re-implants it in the
woman well
um
if the instead of picking the zygote at
random you you examine the genes and
this can be done when it reaches say the
eight cell stage so you let them develop
to the eight cell stage so they are
eight cell embryos and then you can take
out one cell of the of the eight
and look at the genes of that and it
doesn't damage it
and you say oh okay this one
has the gene for hemophilia this one
doesn't why on Earth would you choose at
random if you know
that some that half of them have have
the hemophilia and half of them don't
obviously it makes moral sense to pick
one of the half one of the 50 that do
not have the gene for hemophilia
whatever it might be I suppose the
question that it brings into and this is
part of the other conversation we want
to have with you
um in terms of atheism and religion it
brings into question uh life what is
life is a eight cells I got life can it
be discarded uh is that that that's
where the moral conundrum comes in I
have no time for those that kind of
argument about is this a human life
really no why not well because
this eight cell zygote has no feeling it
has no nervous system it has no capacity
to suffer no capacity to feel pain
um so that there's I mean no no moral
difficulty at all in choosing you're
going to pick one of them anyway what a
dozen of them and the and the 11 that
you that you don't choose are going to
be flushed away anyway
so um you've already taken that moral
decision in a way it's a question of
whether you to choose one at random
whether you choose the one that that
does not have the
but what I mean is once you've created
that selection process given that
parents would want their children to be
happy but also clever and now you've now
you've moved on to quite a different
topics yeah now you moved on to but
that's where I was going okay right so
and that's I think the core of France
yeah too is if we've got the opportunity
to select the optimum baby for us are we
not going to end up in a position where
parents are encouraged to go down that
path well yes incentivize them but
you've changed the subject to like I I
was talking about the removal yeah I'm
not trying to catch you out it's a very
interesting question and and then you
can say something like
um
if it became possible to know that all
these of these dozen zygots that we've
got
um some of them have a gene for musical
genius and some of them don't
um we're nowhere near that at the moment
but but if if in the future that that
came about then would you worry about
parents who say I want my child to
to be a great musician or a great
composer a great mathematician
um and that's very interesting that's a
more difficult moral dilemma
um
if if you object to that then I might
say to you
why do you object to that when you don't
object to parents
even forcing their child to practice the
piano see you know you haven't done your
music practice today get on with it
you're supposed to practice because the
only way you'll become a great pianist
is by practicing
six hours a day whatever it is
um why would you think that is
uh okay when you would not think it okay
to pick out a zygote from a petri dish
which contains a genetic predisposition
to be a great musician I'm not answering
the question but I'm saying that in a
way these sorts of moral questions can
best be answered by comparison with
other other things and I'm just
comparing this case asking sort of
question a moral philosopher might all
might ask
um what's the difference between
encouraging a child to practice the
piano is giving the child a head start
by giving it the
Gene of the of the ones that are
available in the petri dish in an IVF
situation
um to become a musician I suppose the
problem with with that the answer to
that is we come back into the realm of
religion and morality because
I think the core of it is the idea that
the creation of life is some kind of
random Miracle it's supposed to be
sort of it's it's not supposed to be as
a word that I've introduced of course
but if we if we call it a miracle
um it's supposed to be random to some
extent it's supposed to be down to
chance when you when we start
interfering with that selection process
instinctively I I can't explain it
perhaps I feel a certain there's
something off about that
for me I know that's not a very rational
scientific argument but I do think
that's one a lot of people share
actually but it's not rational no I I
acknowledge that it sounds as they are
religious it does it does which I'm not
interestingly but I feel that that is
probably how a lot of people do think
about it yes I suppose they do
um I think it more of a worry would be
if some mad dictator some kind of Hitler
started using these techniques and
mandating you know the selection of
blonde blue-eyed
Aryan
you know
um
the sort of thing Hitler might have
might have selected
um I was talking about more giving
parents the opportunity to have their
um to do the IVF in a non-random way
um I I can sort of see that both ways I
don't I'm like but on the other hand if
you have a dictator who says we want to
breed in this country a race of people
who are who are of such and such a type
um that I think is deeply sinister
foreign